shocker America really really loves guns
a new pew research poll shows sixty
three percent of Americans now believe
having a gun is the best way to protect
against crime with the support for gun
control at a 25-year low if you
suggested that the changes the result of
Americans believing that crime is a big
problem bite statistics showing the
opposite according to Pew it's unclear
why public views on crime have grown
more dire so many blame it on the nature
of news coverage reality TV and
political rhetoric yeah we love guns
we've always loved guns no matter how
many people are killed by guns no matter
how many children are killed in
elementary schools no matter how many
shootings there are you know after
Newtown it sounded like maybe we were
going to get some gun control something
like quote me I think we've talked about
this on tyt something like ninety
percent of Americans wanted stronger gun
legislation after that somehow that
couldn't get past what what is our
fascination with guns well you don't
have to be correct to have when you have
a gun you make everybody agree with you
by pointing a gun Adam then they all for
your force people to pretend that you're
right and so a lot of people can get to
be wrong and powerful as opposed to me I
just have to be correct I'm unarmed so
as to be armed with what I'm saying in
the meaning of it but you can stop and
you any of your dogma can be made
correct the the one with the gun doesn't
have to be right he just has to have
what he's already got the one without
can scream and shout but even if he's
right he still get shot guns we love
guns right i mean this country just
loves gun obviously look again i work
for a network that celebrates classic
Hollywood but but classic Hollywood
played a role in the gun fascination I
mean the most popular movies there in
the nineteen thirties and then into the
40s with the war movies but the thirties
with the westerns the guys we idolize
the heroes they weren't guys with the
best ideas they were the guys with the
biggest guns now you know theory they
were again generally the guys on the
just side but you you made your case by
shooting people by killing people and
you needed a gun to do it uh so that
it's we've been fascinated with guns for
a long time and obviously we want our
freedom by by using guns and and and
beaten the British I mean it is the
media it is the NRA funded media
it is not just fox news but uh local
news stations across the country I
worked in local news for five years that
expression there's never been a bigger
cliche that is more true that if it
bleeds it leads that is one hundred
percent true yeah why not single person
shooter games yes sir you know I don't
know I don't buy that I'll buy land they
they've had many studies saying that
that's not true I play a ton of video
games with people say it all the time I
know but what you ever not like well I
don't know I mean I don't know I I got
it I got it that I don't think that
because first of all single person
shooter games have increased and as
we're trying to get the point across
islands and crime are going down right
so that would indicate that maybe the
guns don't out like this week it might
be an outlet or we're smart enough to
know the difference yes perhaps more
likely what's worse is the coverage of
the games is the conservative coverage
of game suggesting that this makes us
more violent again they love stories
that scare us the Republican Party has
succeeded for 25 years of scaring us
that black people are coming for your
white daughters gay people coming for
your white sons right uh the teachers
are gonna teach your kids how to be gay
the life that you knew and thought you
could control is being lost to other
forces people who are different than you
Isis Isis is coming to coming across the
Mexican border they're leading prayer
rugs down as they stream across the
board never just get through this show
none of it's true yeah we gotta go man
um so we're being scared constantly on
television reality television and then
the news which makes I left local news
because it made no effort to tell people
what was really happening I went to a
show that it did and then no one wants
um but that though it's pretty hideous
like they're you know they'll cover
politics they don't cover politics
interestingly when they do they just
cover the yelling and they basically you
know me of a of a 7-eleven gets robbed
they'll cover that story and show that
tragedy without ever providing any
context that by the way the good news is
is that they'll probably catch the guy
uh and there hasn't the robberies like
this are significantly down since the
eighties massively doubt since cinta
Britt when it started really in the
nineties but these shows O'Reilly and
Hannity and Limbaugh and all these other
guys and to say nothing of local news
stations
across the country thrive and their
success at least they think is built on
scaring us and crime scarce as more than
a right so is the irony with this though
then that despite all the scare tactics
which obviously exists without question
that despite all that we the polls still
show create a huge percentage of people
want more sensible gun control despite
that it's now being compounded with a
secondary set of contradicting fear that
even the certain factions of the white
community are afraid of police now
coming and shooting their dog and
shooting them on their property and that
a new thing that is crossing because new
videos are showing some white people
going under it and it's activated the
crowd that has all these guns the white
group that is writing worried about that
that happening to them now which is a
first yeah so that's interesting so it's
like it's the other thing they used to
scare you from the other now they're
scaring your government supposed to
protect you from the others now scaring
them from that side too so this two
sites Karen yeah I think that's right
fair fear is a you know fear is so
visceral the other stuff is complicated
and it requires you to read fear is
they're coming and like this responds in
so many easy ways to to being men and
being told that like AG to protect your
family or not yet you know I'm a man
I'll protect my family but interestingly
what we are prepared for is I'm prepared
to go buy a gun and fill out a report
now they do a complete background check
and get that gun in seven days well I'm
at least glad we ended up with a little
reason by the way I'm for the Second
Amendment you should be able to have a
gun but yeah seven days you could wait a
couple days they're gonna do some
checking and then you'll get your gun
you get all your ammo and all that good
stuff what do you think about gun
control let us know in the comments
right now